of the loops
[Music]
one of the most unlikely alliances are
the biggest pirate names one piece is a
treasure Trove of legendary Team battles
be it strategy psychological warfare or
pure overpowered Brawn it's got it all
however it's not just for the high
octane action but for furthering
important plot lines and character
development that these fights stand out
so without further Ado video brings to
you the top 10 one-piece Team battles
starting off at number 10 a crazy game
of whack-a-mole proves quite lethal for
Chopper and Uso
[Music]
up
not exactly the strongest members of the
straw hats group they encounter Baroque
Works officer agents Mr four and Miss
Merry Christmas who make a formidable
team compromising a mole human a killer
batter and an explosive sneezing dog
this fight which comes pretty early in
Chopper and Usos Journey as pirates is a
brilliant Showcase of courage and quick
thinking playing the enemy's strengths
against them the straw hats bring them
down in a single stroke almost always
portrayed as a coward usop proves his
metal it is trademarked deceptive style
for a doctor and a sniper the duo
perform astonishingly well in a match of
strength that's not exactly their Forte
more credit to the two because the false
information of Luffy's death not only
fails to break their Spirit but Spurs
them on to Vanquish the enemy all right
[Applause]
[Music]
next up at number nine is the star
alliance between the straw hats and the
Heart Pirates as they face the
charismatic Don Quixote doflamingo
foreign
[Music]
game plan leading to the present
scenario with Luffy providing most of
the muscle the Luffy law Alliance as we
know is still going strong in the wano
arc however Duffy's no pushover fighting
to hold on to his Supremacy toffee
brings the country he rules to the verge
of Destruction and almost kills law who
might not have made it out of life had
it not be for Luffy even the straw Hat's
Captain is forced into a corner the
final moments serve up a Monumental
power-up for the main protagonist and
the fall of a fearsome villain for just
when you think you've seen it all a
sleeping giant awakens the real Kingpin
behind the fake devil fruit trade yonko
kaido enters the stage
foreign
[Music]
number eight is the Monumental climax of
The Paramount war in marineford
it's a bloody Carnival where colossal
powers on both sides Collide but the
stars of the show are Whitebeard and his
division commanders going head-to-head
with the three Admirals Akainu aokiji
and gizaru many arcs later this sport
lives on in our memory not just for the
literal earth-shattering powers that are
displayed but for the principles the
contenders fight for marine Foot shows
white beards resolve to rescue Ace whom
he considers a son even if it means
putting everything on the line including
his own health a preeminent pirate from
the time of gold D Roger when Whitebeard
finally Falls we bear witness to the end
of an era on the one hand we see a
pirate with Noble ideals and on the
other we witness the unscrupulous nature
of the Marines who are ready to use any
underhanded means to achieve victory in
the end it's almost symbolic to see
Marine foot in Ruins while the Resolute
Whitebeard Stands Tall before it even in
death
one piece may be one of the biggest
anime out there but do you know that it
can't be watched legally in some places
luckily for you today's sponsor has
something to say about it introducing
expressvpn the number one VPN service in
the world just like the new world
browsing the internet these days without
a VPN is actually quite dangerous vpns
are a plenty so how do we determine the
best VPN of them all I think the ease of
use is the biggest factor and expressvpn
has that title one no questions asked
with the ability to access so many
different servers from across the globe
bypassing region locks and protecting
your identity has never been this easy
so now you can follow one piece and
never miss a beat legally at that just
go to Netflix open up expressvpn and
click on the Canada server boom now you
can watch your favorite pirates in one
piece without any pop-ups and ads you've
got to experience it yourself so I'll be
giving you a hand all you have to do is
go to expressvpn.com Vinnie tube to get
your first three months free or you
could check the link in the description
box install expressvpn now it's gonna be
the best decision you'll ever make
the seventh spot is Luffy and BJ's
Ambush on big mama she hosts an
extravagant tea party to Mark her
daughter's wedding to Sanji
[Music]
thank you
in a scenario straight out of a fairy
tale with giant animated cakes and
teapots multiple Sinister plots lurked
Behind The Smiling Faces unknown to big
mom or her fearsome children the straw
hats in cahoots with the fire tank
Pirates and the Capone Beach plan to
assassinate her and rescue Sanji the
complexity with which Oda has written
this melee is praiseworthy a dozen
different scuffles break out in the
chaos Luffy heads straight for big mom
his goal is to break a Memento she holds
extremely dear thereby shocking her into
incapacitating herself and giving beads
time to attack this fight stands out for
its brilliant strategy and riveting
action made all the more engaging by the
spectacle that his big mom and her
deceptively cute Army and it once again
cements Luffy's reputation as an icon of
Courage even if it is to the point of
stupidity
thank you
[Music]
number six is the shout out to team
spirit as the straw hats fight an
impossible enemy in the Eerie Thriller
Park Arc
[Music]
thank you
when he was alive almost was known as
the continent puller which says
something about his colossal strength
when the straw hats encounter him he's
an even bigger nightmare as he's been
reanimated with the addition of Luffy's
Shadow the first impression this fight
makes on us is that it shows the straw
hats fight side by side as a crew for
the first time in almost every other
battle they're in the habit of going off
on their own and what's more their
teamwork is effortless regardless of
fighting style power level or any other
differences that they've got working
against the time limit none of them lose
hope but continue to think on their toes
while fighting obese with no apparent
weakness the Faith with which they fight
to the last man in order to buy time for
their Captain is remarkable it makes us
want to see the straw hats Fighters won
again and again
Africa
moving on to number five is the monster
Trio's first assignment on their return
after the time skip
this isn't the first time the straw hats
have encountered the pacifistas these
cyborgs created in the form of the
former chichibukai Bartholomew Kuma pack
almost as much power as a marineford
battleship in a strange stroke of Fate
at the exact location where Luffy and
his crew didn't stand a chance against
the deadly human weapons we get a
rematch giving us a first peak of the
armamentaki Luffy declares the pacifista
to be too slow before one shutting it
into a heap of junk another one follows
close but his two right hands Zorro and
Sanji take care of it in the blink of an
eye in a span of just two years the
three men have grown exponentially in
power bringing them that much closer to
completing their journey and realizing
their dream of obtaining the one piece
worthy of their title of the monster
Trio this demonstration of powers just a
drop in the ocean as we've seen so far
crunch muches don't get better than this
at number four inuarashi and Neko
mamushi Take On kaido's All-Star Jack
the two mink leaders have a score to
settle with Jack for having poison and
tortured their people on Zoe under the
shimmering Moonlight the minks go into
their Soo long forms and boy oh boy they
are magnificent with their accelerated
speed and immense power jack can barely
keep up with them amongst the most
picturesque Jewels 41o this dance under
the Moonlight feels magical and faithful
inwarashi and Neko mamushi not only
defeat Jack but a horde of kaido
subordinates to boot depleting a massive
portion of his fighting force even the
yonko is compelled to acknowledge their
strength here for a very short time the
impact is tremendous however it doesn't
end there inuarashi takes up the
gauntlet once again setting the stage
for a one-on-one fight with Jack that
definitely makes the taste of Vengeance
that little bit sweeter
foreign
and that brings us to the big three Zoro
and Sanji take on the other two of
kaido's All-Stars king and queen
in this battle between the wingmen of
yonko kaido an aspiring pirate king
Luffy who would you bet of the most
anticipated fight of the season the
kickoff most certainly lives up to the
hype just as sanji's having a tough time
battling king and queen together the
heavily bandaged Zorro wakes up thanks
to a miracle drug the wanna walk has
saved some of the most epic entrances
for Zorro and this is definitely one of
those after suffering a terrible injury
fighting alongside the captain against
kaido Zorro heads into the second round
looking better than ever Sanji 2 having
disgraced himself earlier by leaving
black Maria to Robin is resolved to
prove himself and queen is his ticket to
Redemption moments into the fight the
two All-Stars are sent flying
foreign
[Music]
gozuki Odin's most trusted retainers
give it all they've got to avenge their
lord after a torturous 20-year wait
[Applause]
the object of their outrage is kaido in
his dangerous Dragon form but the nine
stand and daunted with their swords
drawn unlike other fights in one piece
this one stands out for its pure
Japanese Essence it's almost like
watching an Akira kurosava Samurai film
especially when the Avengers use Odin's
signature two sword star for the final
attack not lacking in heroism this scene
brings back all the terrible Deeds Done
by kaido including boiling wana's true
ruler Odin in oil for over an hour and
reducing his country to a wasteland the
rage as you can imagine is palpable
pouring in all of their emotions and
regret the nine deliver the final
assault and cut kaido at the exact spot
where Odin had wounded him all those
years ago but good doesn't always
Prevail over evil does it beaten to a
bloody pulp ginimon passes on his
Masters will to Luffy in one of the most
saddest moments in one piece history
it's now time for the winner and by that
we mean the apocalyptic collision
between yonko's kaido and big mom more
beast and human and five of the worst
generation Luffy Zorro kid killer and
lore
all right
in a continuation of the amazing fight
at number two Luffy takes up the mantle
to bring down kaido and free wano for
the Fallen Samurai watching Luffy fight
with you teammates is always refreshing
and each one of them packs a mean punch
too you know Zorro especially excels at
cutting through a colossal combined
attack and slashing through kaido's
extremely tough body which even the
arcaziah 9 failed to do the action is
glorious especially the master class in
conquerors haki which most of the
parties present are capable of wielding
whether consciously or unconsciously but
what makes this fight even more
impactful is the anticipation it raises
an upgrade in power for Luffy is all but
certain even if the Epic encounter ends
prematurely with our hero falling off
the island we can be sure of one thing
when he finally does resurface kaido is
going down oh yes
with so much to look forward to not
forgetting Zorro and sanji's ongoing
fight on the performance floor the
weight is actually that much more than
maddening but hang in there for what's
to come and it's surely going to blow us
away with that thought we come to the
end of this video about the top 10
one-piece Team battles brought to you by
Vinnie tube thanks a lot for watching
please like And subscribe and do let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
until next time
[Music]